Okay. I'm just now caught up on the different
Sunday show interviews that happened this
past Sunday. One was an interview with Bernie
Sanders on CBS face the nation. Bernie Sanders
is running for president in 2020 he's currently
a senator and there was a moment where the
interviewer Margaret Brennan truly embarrassed
herself in trying to sort of play the tough
devil's advocate or giving Bernie Sanders
had gotcha question and it completely imploded
in utter total embarrassment when the topic
of Iran came up. Now before I play that part,
I'm just going to play the first 20 seconds
of this interview, which will immediately
give you a sense of just how dumb and cringy
this interview was. Listened to the strange
sort of a, I don't even know what to call
it, just the entire demeanor of interviewer
Margaret Brennan is bizarre towards Bernie.
Here's a setup of how this interview started.
Thank you very much for making time barred.
Sure. You've been called an existential threat
to the Democratic Party. How much resistance
within the party do you face? Well, first
of all, I've got to figure out what this existential
threat actually means, but what it came from
his third way, which is the corporate wing
of the Democratic Party.
So Bernie does a good job of slowing it all
down at every opportunity during the interview,
reducing the hysteria, but then they get to
the topic of Iran and Bernie starts correctly
criticizing Donald Trump's completely erratic
action on Iran over the weekend, which we
covered where we were bombing Iran. And then
we called off the bombing of Iran and Margaret
Brennan starts playing. I don't know if it's
again, just playing a weird devil's advocate
or playing a semantic game when Bernie starts
talking about war with Iran where she says,
well, war, I mean, you know, it was a limited
strike and Bernie Sanders takes none of it
and he accurately and precisely and concisely
and pithy, uh, destroys that argument.
I want to ask you, uh, about Iran was president
Trump's decision this week to call off that
strike the right one. So it's like somebody's
setting a fire, uh, to, uh, a basket full
of paper and then putting it out or he helped
create the crisis and then he stopped the
attacks. The idea that we're looking at a
president of the United States who number
one thinks that a war with Iran is something
that might be good for this country. He was
just doing a limited strike or just a limited
scar. Oh Wow. I'm sorry. I just didn't know
that. It's okay to simply attack another country
with bombs. Just the limited trucks. That's
an act of warfare.
This is a great example of the different standards
that are applied to the actions of the United
States versus the actions of other countries
by Americans. Okay, and this is one of the
things where it's so refreshing. You know,
I have family in Argentina, I was born there.
I have family in France and different places,
and when I talk to them, it's to talk to people
who are not applying a different standard
to the United States than to other countries.
Because think about it, if any other country
launched a so called limited strike of any
kind against the United States on an American
military base abroad, even everyone would
be on the same page in the U S it's an act
of warfare. Pearl Harbor in a sense it was
a limited strike on a US military base. The
double standard has to stop and I guess I
sort of get the idea that Margaret Brennan
is trying to play devil's advocate here and
be the tough interviewer who's going to hold
Bernie Sanders to account, but she's choosing
all the wrong spots.
It's very ignorant the way she's trying to
do it. If North Korea did a limited strike
in South Korea, would that be a limited strike
or would it be an act of warfare? I think
we all know the answer in some sense. Nine
11 was a limited strike on a very specific
section of New York City and Washington DC.
There was total consensus that it was an act
of war, which was then used to justify not
one but two wars, the war in Iraq, which was
completely unrelated to nine 11 and an escalation
of the war in Afghanistan. So I'm fine debating
any of these foreign policy decisions on the
merits, whether it's Iran, Syria, Venezuela,
China, Cuba policy, Russia. I mean there are
serious conversations to be had about any
of those countries. And I'm not just saying
militarily, but in many different ways. There
are legitimate debates about what US foreign
policy should be and how it has worked or
not worked in the past, but there is this
very dangerous and disturbing tendency for
Americans in a sort of bubble to shrug off
the actions of the American military when
if we reverse the situation, these would be
obvious acts of war, which the same people
would say, Oh wow, that was an act of war.
The U s must now re retaliate against this
act of war, so I don't believe that it's a
useful type of devil's advocacy by the interviewer
Margaret Brennan. I'm curious to hear what
you think about it. I understand playing devil's
advocate, I do it on this show, but I try
to do it in a thoughtful way where it makes
sense. I don't just pick random semantic,
a devil's advocacy and throw it out there
to make it seem like I'm challenging the guest.
I want to be challenging the guests in a way
that is substantive and critically useful.
It's merely sort of manufacturing a context
in which we can then shrug off our own aggressive
acts of violence. What Margaret Brennan is
doing here, it should be denounced and this
is not the type of cover we want to provide
to our foreign policy apparatus, particularly
not when you have a completely clueless and
ignorant president in Donald Trump surrounded
by people who are almost completely off the
rails on hinged when it comes to foreign policy.
People like John Bolton and Steven Miller
and others that are surrounding Donald. It's
straight up irresponsible to do this bogus
Gotcha. Foe Devil's advocacy that was done
here. Good for Bernie though in absolutely
destroying it. Make sure you follow me on
Instagram at David Dot. Pacman. I've got some
great behind the scenes stuff from the studio,
people curious about what things look like
here, uh, and lots of other great stuff. Follow
me there at David Dot pacman and follow the
show on
Brown at David Pakman. Show